- The autopilot relies on a series
of sensors all around the
aircraft collecting data.
- [Narrator] This is Captain Sonya Laxo,
a 23-year veteran at American Airlines.
She, like other pilots,
uses autopilot on every flight,
and while it controls.
- The ailerons, the
flaperons and the spoilers
on both wings, the elevator on the tail
and then as well as the rudder.
- [Narrator] Autopilot isn't autonomous.
She's here to explain
just what it actually is,
how the technology behind autopilot works,
and how it helps her and
her fellow pilots get you
to your destination.
(lively music)
Quick note, Laxo flies Boeing aircraft
and will be using Boeing terminology
but autopilot works similarly
on other commercial aircraft.
- The technical name for the autopilot
is the Auto Flight
Control System, the AFCS.
- [Narrator] The AFCS, or autopilot,
is just one of an increasing number
of automated technologies
in the cockpit, many of which are designed
to prevent dangerous scenarios.
The autopilot system is
there to assist pilots,
letting them take their
hands off the yoke.
- The main components
of the autopilot system
are the autopilot flight director system,
and the auto throttle system,
actually controlled by what
we call the mode control panel
in the flight management
computer, the FMC,
which we, mot of the time,
just call it the box.
- [Narrator] The mode
control panel and the box,
those are both controlled by the pilots
on the flight deck.
- By using the mode control panel,
the flight management computer,
we command that autopilot
flight director system
and the auto throttle system
to perform the climbs,
the cruise, the descents,
the approach, and in
certain circumstances,
the actual landing itself.
- [Narrator] But the autopilot system
extends outside the cockpit.
(pensive music)
- [Sonya] The autopilot
relies on a series of sensors
all around the autopilot collecting data.
- [Narrator] GPS
information, as well as data
on air speed and altitude are fed back
to the computers onboard,
which use the information to determine
if a plane is veering
from its preset route.
- [Sonya] The computers
are always running.
I mean they're very fast speeds.
So any time there's
any little discrepancy,
it's gonna make an adjustment
to keep that aircraft
on that flight profile.
- That's the auto part,
the system's ability
to make those adjustments
to maintain level flight
along a path without pilot input.
- The autopilot's actually
controlling the flight controls.
So it's gonna be the
ailerons, the flaperons,
and the spoilers on both wings,
the elevator on the tail,
as well as the rudder.
- By adjusting those components,
the autopilot is able to
move the plane along one
of three axes.
- We have the longitudinal
axes from nose to tail,
the lateral from wing tip to wing tip,
and then the vertical,
which goes straight down
the middle of the aircraft.
So when the aircraft is rotating
on the longitudinal axis,
it's using the ailerons,
the flaperons and spoilers to do that
and then the lateral axis,
that's using the elevators.
And then your rudder will
be along the vertical axis.
- [Narrator] While autopilot
can move the plane itself,
it's not doing so without supervision.
- The autopilot is a tool.
The autopilot doesn't fly the airplane,
we fly the airplane through the
automation of the autopilot.
So while the autopilot is
maintaining the wings level,
flying the route,
the pilot is always
monitoring the autopilot.
- [Narrator] This relationship
can go both ways, however.
Certain autopilot systems prevent input
from pilots that would, for example,
force the plane to turn too sharply
or raise the nose at too steep an angle.
To understand just how
a pilot uses autopilot,
let's follow a flight's path,
starting at the gate.
- Initially at the gate,
we download the route
into the FMC, the box,
so then the autopilot knows what it needs
to be following as per the route
and also performance,
airspeed, fuel consumption.
- [Narrator] The autopilot
isn't engaged as yet.
The pilots control the takeoff
but they must engage the
autopilot above 28,000 feet due
to vertical separation requirements,
though most pilots
press the button sooner,
letting the autopilot take control.
- Analogy would be the
cruise control in your car.
So it assists the driver
but the driver still has to be aware
of their environment and
react to that environment.
Just like on the flight deck,
we can disconnect the
autopilot at any and all time
and have full control of the aircraft.
- [Narrator] But that isn't common.
Pilots typically only spend a few minutes
per trip manually flying the plane,
though they are required to
do regular proficiency checks
in a flight simulator
during which certain
segments of the flight
must be hand flown.
Once autopilot is engaged,
pilots' jobs don't stop.
- We're constantly working on our tasks
to ensure the safety of our passengers,
getting from point A to point B.
We're not sitting up here
reading the newspaper.
We don't have time for that.
- [Narrator] Instead, pilots
are monitoring the fuel,
planning for emergencies and looking out
for weather ahead,
which could prompt them to
change their instructions
for the autopilot.
- We can use it to either
go around the weather,
either using a heading mode
or actually making changes
into the route itself
to go around the weather.
So the one thing is we're always aviating,
navigating, communicating but with safety
being our number one priority.
- [Narrator] When it comes time to land,
pilots generally disengage autopilot,
and land themselves
but in certain types of
weather with low visibility,
pilots are actually
required to do an auto land.
- You don't have that visual
output out the window,
so that actually helps
but you're again watching it like a hawk
and at any point in time,
if it's not flying the
path it's supposed to fly,
we disconnect it.
- [Narrator] Automation,
including the autopilot system,
has contributed to
record low accident rates
in recent years.
However, it was a faulty
flight control system,
combined with pilot
missteps and other factors
that investigators say led
to two fatal crashes of Boeing
737 MAX in 2018 and 2019.
Boeing has since fixed the system
and revamped pilot training,
and with the FAA's approval,
the MAX is now being used
for passenger flights again.
Meanwhile, airplane
automation is continuing
with companies testing out
increasingly advanced systems aimed
at reducing pilot workload
and enhancing safety.
But for all its advances,
autopilot still has a lot to learn.
- The autopilot cannot
maneuver the aircraft
from the gate to the runway and take off.
Nor can it maneuver the aircraft
from the runway back to the gate.
- [Narrator] For now,
think about autopilot
as an extra set of hands in the air,
following Laxo's detailed instructions.
(lively music)